it's modern
exactly I'm just putting it out there
aqua not woman Mira what should we have
written it down first I memorized it
didn't you oh yeah
what are you just say something
something Trident I gotta talk about
Mira coming up in Aquaman because I'm so
excited for her
and I love the strides that DC has been
making you know on the heels of Wonder
Woman and I know you've said that she is
not a damsel in distress so what was
that something that was really special
and that you considered in taking that
role
yeah they had me a sword and a crown
Zack Snyder and I spoke on the phone and
I didn't really think a comic book world
would be something that would be
appropriate for me I didn't really
knowing nothing about the comic book
world knowing nothing about the universe
I didn't really have any reason to feel
like that would resonate with my
sensibilities or my core principles
I had a limited experience or limited
you know exposure to women in that world
and then he explained this badass
kick-ass where your queen to me and I
thought again sort in a crown okay if I
read the comic book and I remember being
an adult woman sitting in a nail salon
reading a comic book
a that's kind of weird B I remember the
first scene I read in this comic and
they you know Mira my character Smith's
name Mira and her male counterpart
Aquaman played by Jason Momoa they are
you know in the comic book version
saving the town they have just saved a
town from some you know aquatic disaster
hurricane or something of that effect
and you know as the townspeople or the
civilians are picking up pieces of their
life they looked at me and they say
that's Hawkman and they look to Mara and
they were like who are you is that aqua
woman
and she stops what she's doing and she
says I had my own name I'm not awful
woman have my own name my name is Mara
no they ain't get behind that woman yeah
I got a girl this is my girl yeah I like
in the footage we seen - it's like it
she's not she's not like his psychic
they're really working in tandem with
each other and you talk about their
dynamic and what their relationship is
it's a very special dynamic and one that
does not put the burden a dependency on
one or the other
I like that as a woman I'm not relegated
into a position of dependency or
subservience one that is not defined by
the existence of the male counterpart in
which she's providing a bounce I love
that she is self-possessed in control of
her own destiny she's powerful she's new
one she has her own attitudes and her
own problems and they counter that of
his or one is strong specifically
speaking to their dynamic where one is
strong the other is weak and vice versa
they come from two different worlds
quite literally he comes from land she
comes from Atlantis which is in the sea
and in doing that you create a dynamic
that's fair it's balanced its equal they
are both providing for one another that
which they didn't have before so we're
really gonna be wanting a mirror set off
it's modern and exactly I'm just putting
it out there
aqua not woman Meera
[Music]